the spring is now compressed twice as
much to delta x equals 2d a student is
asked to predict whether the final
position of the block will be twice as
far at x equals 60. the student reasons
that since the spring will be compressed
twice as much as before
the block will have more energy when it
leaves the spring so it will slide
farther along the track before stopping
at position x equals 6d
so let's just think about what the
student is saying or what's being
proposed here
so in the first version the first
scenario we compressed the block we
compress the spring by d
and then
we the the spring accelerates the block
and then right when we get back to x
equals zero all of that potential energy
has been turned into kinetic energy and
then the friction
the the friction pro is acting against
the motion of the block so you can view
it as it's providing negative work it's
good the direction of the force is
opposite to the change in our change in
x and that negative work eventually
causes the block to stop and all that
kinetic energy has now turned into heat
and so the block goes 3d now this new
scenario we could call that scenario 2
we are going to compress the spring
twice as far
so now we're going to compress the
spring twice as far
so we're going to compress it by 2d
so this is x equals negative 2d here
and what's being said or what's being
proposed by the student is all right if
we compress it twice as far all of this
potential energy is then going to be con
we're definitely going to have more
potential energy here because it takes
more work to compress the spring that
far and then all of that more potential
energy is going to be converted to more
kinetic energy once we get back to x
equals zero and so not only will it go
further but they're saying it'll go
exactly twice as far
so we are going to go instead of going
to 3d we're now going to go to
60.
now let's let's read let's see the what
the questions are here and actually let
me put a question mark here since
i'm not sure if that is exactly right
so
part b one
let me do this
so we're in part b
one it says which aspects of the
student's reasoning if any are correct
explain how you arrive at your answer
and then part two says which aspects of
the student's reasoning if any are
incorrect explain how you arrived at
your answer
so the student is correct that two times
so compressing more
compressing
spring more
spring
more
will
result
in more energy when the block leaves the
spring result
in
more
energy
when
block leaves the spring
block
leaves
spring
which will result in the block going
further which
will
result
or
the block going farther i should say
which will result in longer stopping
distance
which will result in longer
stopping
stopping
distance
now part two
part two here
which aspect of the student's reasoning
if any
are incorrect explain how you arrive at
your answer
well
two times
i could say let me say compressing
compressing
twice as much
twice as much
does not result in exactly twice the
stopping distance does not
result
in
twice
the stopping distance
the stopping
distance
and we can explain more if we like
we know that potential energy is equal
to
one-half times the spring constant times
how much we compress
squared
so we can say that
energy
energy
grows
with
the square
with the square
of
compression
of how much we compress it compress of
how
much
we
compress
so two times the compression
let me say two times i'll write it out
two times
compression
will result in
four times
the energy
energy and this will result in four
times the stopping distance
four
times
stopping distance four times
stopping
stopping
and distance
i think that does a decent job of
explaining where the student is correct
where the reasoning is correct and where
it is incorrect